fat very fat and very sexy and I am 100%
glorifying obesity there's nothing wrong
with my body fat is not a dirty word if
my body tells me something I will make
sure so you want to hear my hot take on
plus-size travel and why I think every
plus-size traveler should get a free
second and even third seat on an
airplane let's just state facts
plus-size Travelers need more space Oh
no there
Melanie that's a shame she was really
nice being fat is not what kills fat
people what kills fat people is a time
being taken away from our lives by those
who refuse to let us live them it's
giving she can hold her weight it's
giving I'm warm it's giving she never
goes hungry it's giving I'm a great
cuddler today not only is it okay to be
fat as the media would like you to think
just your periodic reminder that your
body is perfect exactly as it is all
bodies are good bodies exactly as they
are but according to the fat activist if
you're eating healthy Whole Foods
instead of processed foods well then you
are fat phobic if you work out because
you want your body to look a certain way
you don't care about health you are fat
phobic yeah it was wild is there was
this University um in Canada that
removed all of the nutritional
information apparently from their the
foods and the that the students are
getting on their meal plans because it
was like too triggering to show the
calories there was a viral video that
went around that was a woman who was God
I want to think she she was a professor
somewhere who was talking about avoiding
certain foods is just fat phobic and
it's not based in science and you
shouldn't deny yourself donuts and that
it it's all you know to call some food
junk food is is incorrect and it's like
how are you how are you ever speaking
public
according to them by eating
ultra-processed sugary Foods fill with
additives and chemicals you are doing
your part in standing up against fat
phobia look at you you Warrior
intentional weight loss so you purposely
saying I want to lose 20 lb is fat
phobic but deep down we all know that
being fat can't be good for you that
it's not healthy or natural that none of
our hunter gatherer ancestors were fat
so why is this movement a thing well
part of the reason is that at the heart
of it lies a lot of money to be made by
pushing this narrative and no we're not
saying it's okay to make fun of fat
people but
this come
[Music]
on the idea behind fat positivity has
been around since at least the 1960s it
first started as a movement to quote
protest discrimination against the fat
end quote but soon it took on a life of
its own this is Bill fabri a
self-proclaimed fat admirer also known
as someone who fetishes about being fat
Bill really didn't like the way his wife
was being treated due to her size and he
was also aned by people making fun of
his sexual preferences so in 1969 bill
fabry created a National Association to
Advance fat acceptance or NAFA NAFA was
his way of fighting against fat
discrimination and it was also a way to
get him and his wife the justice and
recognition he thought they deserved and
the whole movement was not without Merit
see at the time life was not easy if you
were overweight people were a lot less
accepting of fat people back then and
the ' 80s '90s and 2000s were all about
being as skinny as humanly possible and
obviously being that thin was just not
naturally possible for a lot of people
so people found all sorts of ways to
force their bodies to lose extra weight
there was an era of fat dies diet pills
and a long list of eating disorders and
as expected it made people really
unhealthy and that's when body
positivity finally started picking up
steam starting in the early 2010s more
and more celebrities started speaking
out against toxic beauty standards
people like Lady Gaga Taylor Swift and
Elton John they all went public with
their struggles with food and their
weights so suddenly it wasn't just some
random dude trying to justify his fat
fetish anymore real famous people were
actually talking about loving their
bodies the way they were this brought
the body positivity movement all sorts
of attention and it started catching on
now in some ways this was good we don't
want people being anares or for fat
people to be ridiculed but you want to
know who else love this body positivity
movement big
[Music]
food for decades food manufacturers have
been playing both sides you would sell
the masses highly processed unhealthy
food that made them fat and then you
would turn around and create a lowfat
diet alternative to give them the
illusion of dieting take Hines for
example a company known for its high
sugar seed oil fill condiments like mayo
and Ranch Hines created a whole line of
light alternatives for people trying to
lose weight hind also bought Weight
Watchers in 1978 to make even more money
by telling people not to eat their
disgusting products or take slim Fest
for example a meal replacement milkshake
brand that was once owned by unil lever
the same company behind Ben and Jerry's
ice cream and wild sausages see us big
food have perfected the business model
create a problem sell a solution to that
problem and then sell a solution to the
problem that your solution created as
long as people were chasing unrealistic
body weights you were raking in billions
I'm playing both sides so that I always
come out on top but then in the early
2010s a whole new type of diet culture
emerged suddenly people weren't doing
Weight Watchers or zero fat diets
anymore they were turned to stuff like
paleo low carb diets veganism and clean
eating to lose weights instead of light
mayo and diet soda it was green juices
and avoiding anything processed no
processed foods disgusting right it was
a sad few years for food manufacturers
as a whole but as celebrities started
talking about all this loving your body
stuff you saw a glimmer of hope on the
horizon I was and I was body positive
then and I'm body positive now but it's
not my job to validate how people feel
about their bodies body positivity to me
is exactly how we explore it in shrill
which is like it's kind of this ongoing
battle and it's mostly internal cuz I'm
tired of running myself into the ground
with workouts and extreme dieting that
like I thought the past few years was
recovery from an eating disorder when it
actually was just completely falling
into it this was a Goen opportunity you
have been waiting for see as fat
positivity became more mainstream all of
a sudden eating junk food became
empowering people were taking their
anti- dieting a bit far it is okay to be
fat [__] like this brings the movement
down everyone's a feminist until there
is a spider around turns out my body is
a and I'm not fat now if you promoted
anything healthy you were fat phobic you
work out because you want your body to
look a certain way you don't care about
health you are fat phobic and so fat
positivity became a cash cow for big
food which got a lot of other Industries
thinking if food companies could make
bilings telling people it was okay to be
fat why couldn't they do it
[Music]
too
in 2015 Mattel the creator of Barbie was
having a pretty bad year sales were down
for four years in a row and nothing the
company did seem to be helping until
someone at Mattel had a brilliant idea
create a plus-size Barbie the doll will
now come in curvy petite and Tall body
sizes the triple chin the thunder thighs
yeah Barbie's makeover isn't traditional
they're like chubby this one actually
has some muscle it looks really strange
they look body and fat positivity was
spreading across America and so many
Brands were taking advantage of looking
like the inclusive good guy so why
couldn't Barbie get in on it too it
didn't matter that Barbie had always
promoted the skinny white blonde look
because in 2015 the company had really
saw the lights they realized all the bad
influence they were having on kids so
this is what they decided to do about it
so what if the decision to make fat
Barbie got them on the Time Magazine
cover or that it made a massive impact
on their sales they were just trying to
reaffirm the positive values of the
Barbie brand but Mattel was far from the
only brand cashing in a fat positivity
for more than 20 years Victoria Secret
have been making millions selling women
the chance to look like one of their
angels from their world war now annual
runway show that only had one thing on
display young skinny beautiful women the
original Victoria Secret was probably
the least inclusive brand in existence
for its models it was get skinni or get
out except that was not going to fly
with this whole fat positivity movement
that was gaining popularity around the
same time so after all sorts of
controversies around his toxic culture
and ties to people like Jeffrey Epstein
Victor Victoria Secret got rid of their
Angels fashion show and what did
Victoria Secret replace them with
plus-size models ah yes because if I was
a woman this would be the aspirational
brand I would spend my money on but if
you think about it that positivity
marketing made sense in theory if two
out of three Americans are overweight or
OB Beast well we got to appeal to 66% of
the population now don't we that's why
companies like Dove make such a big deal
when it comes to adding bigger models
into their ads conveniently forgetting
to mention that their parent company
unil lover also owned the diet brand
slim fast at the same time along with
fair and lovely a brand that sells
whitening cream for people who want to
lighten their skin tone but hey we got
fat people in our ads so obviously we're
the good
[Music]
guys they say fat is AAL SE today being
fat isn't just something you should
accept and not be ashamed of it's
something you should want it doesn't
matter if your weight is killing you or
if you have obesity related diseases if
you're overweight and proud of it you're
bound to find a community that agrees
with you and it's gotten even more toxic
because the same people who used to
preach about body positivity and
inclusivity have become just as
judgmental as a skinny culture before
them now the fashion industry May
persist to label me as plus-size but I
like to think of it is my
size
people are being shamed for calling
themselves plus- eyes because they're
not fat enough and even people who are
body positive but want to lose weight
for health and personal reasons are
Under Fire when the singer Adele managed
to lose a lot of weight to deal with her
anxiety people said they felt betrayed
by the fact that she wasn't fat anymore
this resonates with everybody delicious
pasta resonates with everybody that's
why so many women were mad when Adele
lost all that weight yes like no [__] I
don't want to give up on this [__]
pasta yeah I was with you when you were
big why wouldn't you want to applaud
someone who did something that's really
difficult to do and is now healthier
yeah if you are an Adele fan wouldn't
you want her to be healthier wouldn't
you I mean you want her to be able to
keep singing for longer right you love
her you want her to be healthier one of
the main things they found in in New
York City about people that caught coid
19 that was a real problem was obesity
big problem she was at one point time
much larger and now she's like really
Slim and people are mad and saying this
is what they're saying I don't want her
to be applauded for losing weight as if
it's some some to some wording like this
like that I don't want to adhere to
these beauty standards that she's better
looking because she lost weight but she
is y and you know that the only reason
why anybody would want to fight against
that when so many people overwhelmingly
thinks she look better is because they
don't want to look at themselves it's
that simple they don't want to change
and they want you to they're trying to
bully you and deciding they're beautiful
if they're 210 lbs that's that's really
what it is it's like we're redefining
beauty standards you can't do that you
can't decide that the way you look is
what everybody should like that's crazy
you can't do that when the actress Rebel
Wilson started in Pitch Perfect her
contract blocked her from Gaining or
losing one than 10 lbs because she just
wouldn't be the same lovable funny fat
girl without all that extra weight and
when she actually lost a lot of weight
later to help with her fertility issues
her transformation was called toxic and
depressing the fat positivity movement
has completely spared out of control 74%
of Americans now are overweight or obese
of that
74% 42% are obese and in some ethnic
groups that number of obese is over 50%
of the population and about
52% of American adults have a
essentially completely preventable
pre-diabetes or type 2 diabetes and of
note 90% do not know that they have it
this is Dr Casey means by the way she's
the co-founder of levels a company
that's helping people better understand
how different foods affect their health
it's gone so far that people are
refusing to be weighed at their doctor's
office and that anyone who talks about
obesity related diseases are committing
hate crimes when cancer research UK put
out ads warning people that obesity
causes cancer and that obesity was the
second biggest preventable cause of
cancer after smoking comedians Sophie
Hagen seriously accused them of bullying
in that that being fat doesn't mean
you're unhealthy but is it true is it
true that being fat does not mean that
you're
[Music]
unhealthy there's an energy crisis in
our bodies that is a root cause pathway
of pretty much every chronic disease
we're seeing today but we are just
objectively ignoring it that root cause
link and we are abjectly failing at
managing it and that and I I mean
abjectly failing very seriously so we're
eating about 25 times more refined sugar
than we were a 100 years ago you know
around 100 pounds per year per person
versus about 6 lb in the 1800s when
you're fed all of your body's natural
processes the things humans have been
doing for thousand of years become much
harder having kids is harder when you're
fat moving your body is harder when
you're fat healing wounds and injuries
take longer when you're fat even just
breathing is harder when you're fat the
human body was just not meant to be fat
a body that looks like this isn't going
to function in the same way as a body
that looks like this simply put there is
nothing healthy or empowering about
being fat and no we shouldn't shame
people for being fat but convincing
yourself that you can be healthy at any
size is just a flat out
lie but that still begs the question if
you are overweight how do you actually
become healthier because contrary to
popular belief overweight people do not
usually eat that much more food compared
to the rest of us sometimes they do but
most of the time they don't and yet no
matter how hard they try to diet and
exercise they can never seem to lose
weight why is this well according to Dr
Casey means it might be because their
metabolic health is completely out of
whack what is metabolic Health it's
basically how well your body can turn
food into energy if your metabolism is
good you'll turn more of the food you
eat into energy but if your metab AB
olism is bad or you have metabolic
dysfunction that's when you're going to
have uncontrollable weight gain diabetes
cancer and so on and if you look at how
fat Americans are it's not a surprise
that 93% of Americans are metabolically
unhealthy that's right if you live in
America your metabolism can likely be
improved and one of the best ways to
improve your metabolism is by keeping
your blood sugar in check also known as
your blood glucose see whenever we eat
carbs like bread pasta sugar those carbs
get broken down into glucose and that
glucose enters our BL bloodstream we
need glucose but when we're constantly
spiking our blood sugar from what we eat
it can mess up our body's natural
processes and lead to a ton of health
problems we're talking type 2 diabetes
obesity heart disease stroke dementia
infertility to more subtle things like
always being tired or having low energy
these all stem from not having your
blood sugar in check so if you want to
become healthier if you want to lose
weight have more energy not be tired all
the time you need to be tracking your
blood sugar and if you want the easiest
way to track your blood sugar then you
might want to check out Dr Casey means
this startup levels levels helps you
track your blood sugar in real time with
the levels I pair with A continuous
glucose monitor I'm able to see in real
time how different foods Spike my blood
sugar so I know what foods to keep
eating and what foods to cut out levels
uses a bio sensor that you attach to
your arm that tracks your blood sugar in
real time via its smartphone app and a
ton of people have used it to lose a lot
of Weights I'm personally not looking to
lose weight for me my priority is having
as much energy as humanly possible I
never want to be in the food coma
because I have a lot I want to
accomplish and food food Comas come from
eating foods that spike your blood sugar
I've learned that pretty much all carbs
besides fruit Spike my blood sugar a lot
and it's why I always get food combos
from eating breads or pastas as you can
see with these bikes I wasn't too
surprised by that but what was
surprising is how little carbs I had to
eat for this to happen I could have a
meal of mainly steak and a little
potatoes or a little flour and I would
still get a giant Spike so now I know
for sure that I should only eat meat and
fruit throughout the day while saving
the heavy cars for dinner and setting up
levels is simple you pick the sensor you
want on their website I chose descom
because it transmits data real time via
Bluetooth you'll get your transmitters
and sensors in the mail and from there
you just follow their setup guide attach
the sensor to your arm it feels like a
little pinch but then it feels like it's
not even there you then pair it with
your phone and you're done the sensor
lasts 10 to 14 days depending on the
model and you can replace it while
keeping the same transmitter I'm excited
to keep using levels because there's
still a lot of other Foods I want to
test out and it's why I think everyone
should try this at least once even if
you don't plan on wearing this forever
it's the first time you can get a near
instant feedback loop without having to
prick your your finger so you can
optimize your health way faster over
50,000 people use levels and they love
it so if you want to learn how different
foods affect your health go to levels.
l/j Tren today by scrolling down and
clicking the link
[Music]
below